if it's not in the calendar it won't get
done it's not really a priority you have
to make sure that it's in your plan it's
in your day that is my life this month
as you can see it's color coded it's
beautifully designed and as I flick
through this what you'll realize is that
every single day I have everything from
workout time to meal times uh to
scheduled off time all in my calendar
what this allows me to do is it helps me
prioritize both personal and
professional commitments and helps me
see both things in the same place if you
haven't put something in your calendar
even if it's something social I promise
you you'll either forget it or you won't
plan effectively around it when I know I
have a really big podcast or a really
big interview or if I know that I have a
big deadline on a day I don't then
surround that day with other difficult
and challenging tasks sometimes I'll
start my day with the most challenging
task of the day because I feel that I
need to start with the challenge and
sometimes I'll actually put it as the
last most challenging task of the day
because actually I want to build that
momentum when you have a schedule you
get context around how you feel that way
you manage your mental health and
well-being a million times better and
you do more with less time need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Jay Shetty and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two focus on your breath a
lot of us feel physical mental pressure
throughout the day and one of the
reasons why we feel that is because
either our mind is ahead of our body or
our body is ahead of our mind so I'll
explain what I mean so often how many
times have you had it anyone who's
listening right now I'm sure you can
relate how many times have you had it
where you're running to your next
meeting so your body's moving really
fast but your mind's going I wish we
were still in bed right your mind is
still tired your mind's still feeling
fatigued from the day before or whatever
it may be and sometimes we have it the
other way around your mind's racing it's
saying okay we've got this to-do list
and now we've got this to do and now
we've got this to do and your body's
going ugh Why can't I just be Friday
already why can't it be the weekend
because your body's tired so what we
generally experience in our life is
either our bodies ahead of our mind or
our minds ahead of our body and that
creates friction that's a disconnect in
our life and we were just talking about
this that we feel alignment when what we
think what we say and what we do that's
when we feel Harmony right so the way to
do that one really practical tip I do it
all the time especially when I'm rushing
onto stage to speak at a conference or
I'm walking into a meeting and it's been
a long day or whatever it is I focus on
my breath and what I do is that I
breathe in for the same amount of time
as I breathe out so when you breathe in
for a count of four and breathe out for
a mental count of four and you imagine
the numbers in your heads you want to
breathe in and count to four in your
mind and you want to breathe out and
count to four in your mind you're
aligning your mind and your body because
now your breath is breathing in for four
that counts in your head and then you're
breathing out for four and the counts in
your head so what you've basically done
is taken either your body and your mind
whichever one was ahead or behind and
brought them back in alignment and
they're back in sync totally back in
sync and it works every time rule number
three use fear in a positive way I
realize that fear could be healthy or
unhealthy based on how I used it
and most of us don't realize that we get
consumed by fear instead of using fear
so fear becomes our being in the sense
that
fear becomes what controls us it tells
us what we should do and what we
shouldn't do it tells us how we should
think and we shouldn't think it stops us
from doing stuff that's really important
to us and it makes us do things that we
would never ever do it makes us say
things to people that we love that we
would never want to say to them and on
the other end it stops you from saying
things you really want to say to someone
because you don't want to appear weak
and your ego won't let you Sophia takes
this really magnetic controlling effect
on our whole lives but fear at the same
time can be one of the healthiest things
because it's basically giving you a
signal
as to what's important it's basically
giving us a signal as to how you feel
and when you use it as a signal not as a
suggestion or a push it changes
everything so let's let's make that
practical when you are in your home and
if the fire alarm goes off
that gives you a signal to say check for
the fire check if there's a fire right
now if you go oh just turn it off it
doesn't matter let's let's avoid my fear
let's avoid it let's just turn it off
let's forget about it your house could
bend down or if you're lucky there was
nothing and it's fine but the odds are
that there could be a fire
now if you're someone who goes well let
me inspect it let me be curious about
that I am scared that there's a fire in
my house now that I've heard the fire
alarm but let me be curious let me
inspect let me check
imagine we approached our fear in that
way imagine every time I felt scared of
something I said well let me get curious
about this why am I scared of this why
is it affecting me so much what about
this scares me is it all of it or is it
just a part of it when you start doing
it you start to break that fear down and
that's the healthy way of looking at
fear rather than the unhealthy way of
saying forget about it keep it away from
me I don't want to go there and so for
me I really feel that
fear is what blocks us from these
beautiful breakthroughs in life and it
has such a choke hold on us like it's
such a strong hold on us and I think
most of us are living Our Lives because
we're scared of what someone will say
what someone will think or what someone
will do
and that feels like something that we're
going to regret when we're at the end of
our Lives rule number four let go of
your phone usually during that quality
time with Riley I'm not on my phone I'm
not on my devices but it's at this point
that I finally turned my phone onto
airplane mode I find that this habit is
a game changer and a lifesaver at the
end of the day because it can be so
addictive to just mindlessly scroll
through Instagram or Tick Tock just
before you're about to go to bed and
literally fill your mind up with so much
stimulation that it can be really
difficult to switch off I found that
letting go of your phone an hour before
you go to bed allows you to have so much
more Stillness and calm internally and
externally I really believe that if you
can Master this one habit of not looking
at your phone before you go to bed it
will truly change how you feel the next
morning also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five use visualization one
of the reasons why I love this one is
everyone from Lewis Hamilton through to
David Beckham has used visualization yes
so Lewis Hamilton would visualize the
race track before actually driving in a
Formula One race David Beckham would
visualize a free kick before taking a
shot at a World Cup Tournament and this
visualization allows you to deal with
the pressure and stress before the
actual activity what it does is it
allows you to fast forward it's almost
like time dilation you're fast
forwarding an experience and bringing it
to the present where you're not
experiencing that pressure and stress
right so that you can engage with it
better so if you're scared for example
for if you've got a really big meeting
or a big pitch coming up
if you live that meeting and visualize
that meeting now and visualize yourself
walking in with confidence visualize
yourself not falling over on the stage
right visualize yourself starting that
first word that you say with composure
with eloquence with Effectiveness then
when you actually walk into that space
tomorrow you're going to carry that
energy with you and this is one of the
biggest mistakes we make that we stress
before right but we don't prepare before
and so visualizing what's about to come
reduces this reduces the stress because
it lets you deal with it now and it lets
you plant thoughts and energy into the
future and that's really what a
visualization is doing right it's
letting you plant the energy of feeling
composed and relaxed now into that
feeling so what I do before I'm about to
go on stage I always visualize myself
walking on the stage and I do that to
make myself feel comfortable and
reminding myself I'm not going to trip
on stage you know which we all fear as
speakers and and it allows me to feel
confident and before I walk on so
visualizing any experience a meeting a
lecture or an exam whatever it may be a
test whatever it is you're doing and
it's like mental rehearsal totally
that's all it is the mind doesn't know
the difference between something you
fearfully imagine and something that's
real and most people could use that
superpower if you will for something
negative like visualizing something they
fear was going to happen and then
they're actually practicing that in
advanced also totally yeah and that's
what we mostly do we mostly mentally
rehearse what could go wrong right so we
mentally rehearse tripping up ongoing
why would you do that
we we do that because we think we think
dwelling on our stress and pressure
helps deal with it right but it doesn't
dwelling on anything increases it yes so
the only way to deal with it is to
reprogram ourselves you've just been
speaking about this to reprogram
ourselves to deal with it how we want in
the aspirational sense rule number six
know when to quit I from a very young
age just felt
there was this strong inner voice and I
believe everyone has it this isn't me
being religious or spiritual or woo-woo
this is me saying that there is a voice
that we all hear in our minds in our
hearts in our heads wherever you want to
say it is it's there and
the challenge that happens is in our
early years you're told to tell it to be
quiet so every time that voice says well
maybe no no no no no just just do what
they're saying do what they're told
get on that conveyor belt get on that
assembly line
stick that barcode on your back become a
machine go be a robot and and it's
almost programmed and so that voice that
is not machine like that voice is the
human inside of us is being trained to
be a machine and so we start treating
ourselves like machines and machines you
just program them and then press enter
and then it gives you what it wants but
we don't function that way we're a
conversation in the universe we're not a
program and so if you're a conversation
and you're an interaction you're dynamic
that inner voice becomes so squashed
that now by the time we're 20 30 40 50
60 70 whatever age you are you can't
hear it anymore so you say oh that's
some spiritual mumbo jumbo stuff because
I don't hear that voice rule number
seven keep a journal this is probably
one of the highlights of my evening is
taking out my five minute journal the
genius Jay Shetty version and filling
out the rest of the reflections for the
day I found that this is one of the most
calming and centering moments of my day
because it gives me an opportunity to
appreciate what I have to remember the
incredible moments that have happened
throughout my day see we have so many
highlights in our lives that we forget
simply because we don't take a moment to
allow them to go inward for me this is
like taking a mental and emotional
picture of a moment that I never want to
forget and as you can see today I had
the pleasure of interviewing Jocko
willink who fascinated me with so many
insights guy Roz from how I built this
and then finally just getting to spend
so much quality time with my team I
purposely try to do this in a separate
space in an area that has that grounded
energy remember time has memory and
location has energy when you do
something in the same space every day it
builds a habit it builds an energy it
builds a space and so for me creating
that environment that helps me be
reflective and introspective and
grateful is really a big part of it now
you may have heard about something known
as decision fatigue I first came across
this concept when reading the organized
mind by Daniel Leviton it's the idea
that we make so many decisions first
thing when we wake up in the morning
that we run out of energy to make the
most important decisions of the day so
usually when we wake up we're trying to
figure out what do I have for breakfast
what am I going to wear today what do I
have to do today what tasks do I have to
finish today and then by the time you
start the tasks you've already run out
of energy rule number eight set monthly
goals how many of you feel like the
months are just passing by and it's
crazy to believe there were over a
quarter of the way through the year
but this is what happens when we don't
have really clear goals targets and
tasks this approach has really helped me
manage my time better I have big monthly
goals I have four weekly targets and I
have one daily task the one daily task
is the baby step towards the weekly
Target and the weekly Target added up
all four of them leads to the big
monthly goal so what you're doing here
in essence is breaking down something
that feels quite unachievable impossible
to do and quite challenging into small
manageable chunks sometimes you can be
sitting there thinking wow I don't know
how I'm gonna get that done by the end
of this month if you've ever felt that
way use this model first come up with
how can you break that Big Goal down
into four separate tasks once you have
these four weekly targets now all you
need to do is divide each weekly Target
into a daily task so basically you end
up working on something daily that you
achieve weekly which helps you achieve
something monthly now you've completely
deconstructed this impossible
unachievable idea into something very
simple and manageable rule number nine
schedule time for you the first thing
you want to do is put something in your
schedule in your calendar which is time
for you if you look at your schedule you
would never cancel an important meeting
with someone else but we don't even
schedule one with ourselves there is
nothing in the calendar that time with
myself time for me time for you time for
just this this whole thing that's going
on right now literally put it in for
five minutes a day it's gone in five
minutes driven two minutes a day just
put it in there because if you start
putting that in there you might then
tomorrow go okay well what am I going to
do with this time I've got five minutes
wow okay what am I gonna do with it so
start putting it in there that's the
first step the Second Step I would say
is definitely focus on your breath I
think the breath is just some something
we can all relate to it's tangible by
the way athletes have to learn how to
control their breath musicians have to
learn how to control their breath
whether you're a Dell or whether you're
a football player you have to learn how
to breathe in order to perform me you
and everyone we're all athletes in
different ways we all use our bodies we
all use our minds whether you're a
business person or whether you're an
actual athlete playing on a on a court
or a pit but he's saying that I don't
know how to breathe I am saying you
don't know how to breathe yeah and not
you specifically I'm saying that most
people don't know how to breathe and I
didn't know how to breathe until I was
taught how to breathe and I know that
sounds ridiculous but how many times a
day do you get out of breath I know
there's times a day that I get out of
breath how many times of the day do you
feel that when you're experiencing an
emotion your breath changes like when
you're crying or you're sad or you're
upset your breath changes when you're
happy and elated your breath changes so
our breath is connected to every single
emotion
so if we want to navigate our emotions
and our life we have to train our breath
so I would just say to everyone take out
two to three minutes and just take a
moment to breathe in and out and breathe
in for four and out for four just try it
as simply as that now if you're someone
who struggles to get to sleep which can
often be something that I think everyone
struggles with that's when you want to
breathe out for longer than you breathe
in so if you're breathing in for four
breathe out for more than four to relax
and rest your body and if you're one of
these people that goes Jay I've got you
know I've got like you said I've got to
do a delivery today I've got to run to
this meeting I've got to get to this and
you need more energy breathe out for
less time than you breathe in so you may
breathe in for a second and breathe out
for a millisecond it's a really sharp
breath out and if you do that you'll
feel this pumping energy in your body
and so to me it's these are really
practical tools that I think we all need
to sleep so everyone knows their
meditation for sleep we all need to get
energized so that's a simple meditation
of energize and we all need to just feel
like we're not rushing yeah so I think
those are hopefully quick things that
feel practical to anyone and everyone
and Rule Number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is set
your intention the penultimate thing
that I do just before I go to bed is to
pray and set my intention
this prayer usually involves thanking
God thanking my teachers thanking my
mentors and it also is a prayer of
wanting to be of service of resetting my
intention to not be distracted from
wanting to serve to have a positive
impact on others to be kind and loving
and to be an ambassador of compassion in
everything I do
I often repeat the affirmations just
before I go to bed to help me rest
better they are I am happy healthy and
focused this is how I'm trying to
program my mind the night before for how
I want to wake up the next morning
remember when you set an alarm you said
it the night before so that it wakes you
up in the morning you also program your
mind in the same way you set the
intention or the affirmation the night
before and you'll wake up with that
energy I'll sometimes add the
affirmation I am energized nourished and
ready to get on with my day I want to
wake up feeling that way and often when
we wake up the first thing we say to
ourselves is I'm tired groggy or drained
so we're programming ourselves to feel a
certain way and helping our subconscious
mind prepare itself
I really want you to think about how
Envy is the art of counting another's
blessings not your own start with
compassion don't judge yourself don't
criticize yourself don't compare
yourself don't complain get rid of the
three C's comparing complaining and
criticizing get rid of them out of your
vocabulary get rid of them out of your
mind just totally remove right anytime
you see yourself compare complain or
criticize stop doing it notice it that's
your mind your mind wants to compare
your mind wants to complain your mind
wants to criticize your intelligence
wants to care it wants to be
compassionate he wants to choose with
confidence he wants to be confident
right let's replace those feelings with
that let's replace them for that take
the next month take the next 30 days and
every weekend plan a new activity
Workshop seminar course book podcast to
listen to person to shadow person to
experience with take a Saturday and
Sunday and try it out you've got a eight
things that you can now test there are
eight days eight weekends in a month
roughly test something new on each of
those go and actually do something so
this is no more thinking no more
reflecting if you want to be a chef or
you think you want to be a chef go and
do a cooking class see how natural it
was for you see how much fun you had
doing the process take eight different
things and try them out when you do both
of those together within 30 days you
could figure out what you genuinely are
passionate about as a starting point
that may change it may evolve but at
least you've got somewhere to start and
the biggest mistake is we're sitting
there doing a personality test trying to
figure out what our passion is obviously
you're not gonna know this is the time
to really question the intent behind
what you're chasing to really question
what you want and your intent behind it
because so often our wrong intention for
the right thing will lead you down the
wrong path and I think we don't realize
that when we came to our alignment that
beautiful statement you shared about you
know it's it's not the achievement it's
alignment alignment means is my
intention aligned with my action and
when I'm saying aligned I'm saying is am
I looking for the right thing in the
right way uh and and sometimes even if
you're looking for the wrong thing but
in the right way you'll still get there
that's why intention is so powerful like
if you're planting seeds in your garden
and you by mistake water the seeds but
you water a weed next to it because
you're still watering the seeds are
still going to grow and you'll spot the
weed so that process of watering needs
to continue I want you to think back to
a moment where you felt you were in your
element where you thought you were in
flow it may have been a challenging
situation but to you it felt somewhat
effortless you were performing an
activity you were doing some sort of
teamwork with another group now the
challenges that we usually think of when
someone asks you to think of your
passions we immediately start thinking
of hobbies like art music drama right
science whatever it is we start thinking
of containers because for a long long
time in our lives we've been trained to
believe that everything comes in boxes
everything comes in containers we think
of careers as containers we think of
careers as boxes but the incredible
thing about finding your passion is that
our passions are more like environments
that we thrive in
right our passions or our Natures as
they're called in ancient Traditions is
actually environments a group of
elements coming together that means
someone can Thrive it may mean for you
that you work better in teams it may
mean for you that you work better alone
those are environments environmental
signals that you can find if you're just
conscious and aware of when you're in
flow when you're excited when you're
making a difference when you're making a
change Harvard did a table which I
really believe is what mindful speaking
is all about so what is this so it's
called the it's called Harvard list of
emotions but I I kind of change the name
to emotional vocabulary because I think
it sounds better
so an emotional vocabulary if you look
at all of the world's emotional
vocabulary it's very limited we use five
words to describe pretty much everything
good bad yeah okay fine so it's like
how's your week going good how's your
day been bad how are you feeling okay
literally like we use such limited words
and that may be okay for the majority of
people
but in your personal relationships it's
so important to expand your emotional
vocabulary so this table that Harvard
has made which anyone can find just by
typing in Harvard list of emotions on
Google
what that does is that it shows you that
when you say you're sad what are you
actually been so it gives you all this
list of emotions that sit under the word
sad are you irritated are you offended
are you disappointed have you been let
down the more you expand your emotional
vocabulary the more you can diagnose how
you feel interesting and the more you
can tell your partner or your friend
this is how I'm feeling this is how I'm
actually feeling and and this is one of
the biggest mistakes with words is that
we think our words mean the same thing
now when you say love you might think
forever and when I say love I might
think for tonight right and that is
literally how the word love or care or
marriage or forever gets misused abused
and thrown about because we both mean
different things and our meanings are
based on our backgrounds our beliefs our
beliefs about how we were born and how
our parents are experience everything
yeah it forms our meaning so I really
believe that in a relationship in our
communication with words Define words
when you say yeah we're best friends or
friends what does that mean to you when
we're business partners what does that
mean to you a contract in a financial
legal sense is to define the terms right
but in our emotional sense we also need
to define the terms and we don't do that
emotionally enough and that's why we
feel emotionally like someone broke the
contract and you have nothing to hold
them to because you never made a country
you never communicated you never
communicated the meaning of these words
exactly and that's why words are so
powerful but they're only powerful when
we agree on the definition turn off your
notifications and turn on chill relaxing
work music I've done this for such a
long time where I have a playlist that I
listen to that allows me to just get
into the Zone what I find music does
especially instrumental music that's
what I focus on I try to stay away from
popular music that I may listen to in
the car or while I'm in the gym what
that does is it gives the mind enough
distraction enough Rhythm enough pattern
enough momentum so that you can actually
Focus your mind on the activity at hand
now some of you may prefer silence or
working to chatter and that's fine too
you can even put that type of music on
but for Me instrumental beats and
rhythms are a fantastic way of getting
into the Zone turning off your
notifications is just a no-brainer if
you're really trying to do some deep
work if you're someone who finds that
you're always procrastinating you're
always over analyzing overthinking and
you're struggling to get stuff done this
video is for you the first step is
identifying why we procrastinate how
many of you have ever wondered why do I
overthink I want to get this done I want
to make progress in my life but for some
reason I just can't seem to stop
Alexander Rosenthal who's a
procrastination researcher explains the
four types of trigger we procrastinate
because of expectancy value time or
impulsivity people procrastinate because
of a lack of value associated with the
task or because they expect that they're
not going to achieve the value they're
trying to achieve or because the value
is too far from you in terms of time and
finally because you're very impulsive as
a person what's interesting about
understanding where your procrastination
comes from is that it allows you to
understand what the challenge is and
what the issue is without blaming
yourself without thinking that something
is wrong with you and actually the
clearer you get about the value you're
going to get from the task the amount of
time you do have to dedicate to it don't
judge your soul so many of us when we
procrastinate and overthink start to
feel that there's something wrong with
us we judge ourselves we make ourselves
feel guilty we say negative things about
ourselves to ourselves and to others we
start saying things like I'm so lazy I'm
so worthless I'm not good enough I'm not
smart enough this doesn't make you more
productive more proactive or more
effective how many times is putting
yourself down made you lift yourself up
I don't think those two things go
together what ends up happening is that
when we judge ourselves for being
procrastinators we create a prison of
guilt this becomes a space that we
actually can't break out of and it's how
procrastination Keeps Us trapped by
making us believe that we can't do
anything that we're no better so we need
to stop judging ourselves how do we stop
judging ourselves by letting go
realizing that we all make mistakes and
that we're going to leave that all
behind and we're going to turn over a
fresh page that we're going to start
anew when you're with loved ones when
you're with family when you're with your
friends make a vow to not use technology
if you need to have I've seen these
around where you have a technology jar
and everyone puts their phone in it at
the start of a dinner and takes it at
the end make a vow that when you're with
your friends when you're with your
family that you will not be on your
phone and leave your phones in the same
place in one area so that none of you
can just get that sneaky moment I have
to take a look at it when you first
start you may be worried that you're
going to be bored of each other you
might even be worried well how's this
person going to compete with my phone
how are they going to entertain me I
mean my phone has access to every form
of entertainment
sit in that discomfort again
and in that discomfort you want to learn
something new about that person you're
going to become more Curious your mind
actually has the opportunity to start
building a different Bond earlier I
mentioned that you want to create no
technology times in your home you also
want to create no technology zones in
your home in mine and Rodney's home
those spaces are the dining table and
the bedroom those are two areas that we
want to be technology free that we've
designated as important areas of
connection and so the dining table and
the bedroom becomes places and zones in
my home where we don't use technology
the pressure of finding your purpose
will stop you from finding your purpose
literally yeah the pressure is so heavy
and that's why it's not about finding
that it's just starting with the basics
what am I good at and I talk about it
and I break down Dharma in here and I
talk about what are your passion what is
your expertise what is your compassion
because that's really important what is
your compassion for the world like what
problem do you want to solve I often
people always say there's so many things
I could do there's so many things I'm
like my question is not what causes you
the greatest joy sometimes my question
is what is what causes you the greatest
pain make that your purpose make that
your purpose if you don't know what your
joy is you definitely know what your
pain is not like and so for me go serve
that thing 100 so for me the greatest
pain I see in the world is people not
reaching their potential that is that
causes me more pain because I believe
that there is someone out there who is
stacking shelves who has the cure to
cancer there is someone out there or
who's talented singer he's a talented
singer there is someone out there who's
not living to their potential and I
think we're better people we're better
partners and we're better parents when
we live to our potential so that's what
I'm trying to solve and I'm not saying
that's the biggest thing sure I'm saying
it's my thing what is Faith to you Faith
to me like the two polarities is the
day-to-day practices and the map
so it's the thing that's guiding every
decision right it's the thing that's
guiding every direction that I move in
it's the thing that guys who I want to
be friends with who I want to connect
with the type of work I want to do but
then it's also what I do daily and to me
that's what's so beautiful about faith
that it can be practical and simple but
then it can be philosophical and
spiritual yeah and so to me Faith is
both because if I'm not practicing on a
daily basis how can it last right and if
it's not the governing thing behind all
my decisions then how is it true like
how is it real and how is it your moral
compass also exactly yeah so for me it's
both of those things at all times and so
it's everything I do in the morning so
my meditation practices my prayer the
way I communicate how I speak to my wife
like I think all of those things I
always speak to anyone right I think all
of those things in my faith and at the
same time it's like do I am I doing this
out of love am I doing this out of
service am I taking this decision just
because it pays the bills and just
because it makes money or am I doing
this just because I think it'll be cool
it's the same as it's so funny you ask
me this question because I was speaking
to someone about you just before coming
the show today yes I was saying one of
the things I love about Ashley and why I
think we get along so well and we find
it so easy to connect is because we're
both have such deep Faith yes and I said
I always find it easier when you meet
someone who has their faith and it may
be different but they're open yep and
then you just connect and that's how I
feel with you that when we first started
talking a meeting I felt it straight
away the people who are really rooted in
their faith and that comes before
anything else I always connect yeah how
do you help people
develop their strengths and recognize
what their strengths are in the first
place and calm that monkey mind so that
they can see clearly
Tom
you're just amazing I mean tell me
you're literally explaining my book for
me I'm just like this is like the
biggest masterclass of the book it's
great uh no and you're spot on that the
monkey mind is what we all experience
every day so the monkey mind is jumping
from Branch to Branch it doesn't want to
focus on the root of the issue it wants
to find the next banana it wants to find
the next excuse it wants to find the
next instant gratification right that's
the monkey mind and so the monkey mind
is never going to help you focus on your
strengths
and the reason going back to one of the
earlier questions you asked the reason
why we struggled to find our passion is
because the world has constantly pushed
us away from our strengths we've
constantly been told to focus on your
weaknesses oh you've got three A's and a
d you should be working on that D let's
get that up to an a right I remember in
my school they had this excruciating
exercise where you'd be ranked 1 to 180
on every subject every year and they'd
send the list home to your parents so
there were 180 students in my year group
and every subject art math English
science geography history you name it
you were ranked one to 180 in every
subject based on your test results and
scores and that was like painful when my
parents received that and the crazy
thing was I would always outperform
always in art design philosophy and
economics I was in English I was always
in the top half if not in the top
quarter if not in the top five right of
my whole year group and stuff like
science and geography and math I was
kind of like in the middle
and and towards the bottom end of my
year now granted I went to a competitive
school so I was still okay at those
things but the interesting thing was
that my parents and my friend's parents
would never look at what you came one or
two or three in they'd be looking at the
things you came 90 100 and 110 in and so
we've all been programmed to say oh your
strengths are they're fine they're good
the way they are but why are you not
performing at this
and so the one way to know your
strengths
is to ask yourself what do you do that
you feel the most confidence doing and
it could be something as simple as I'm
great at organizing birthday parties it
could be like that may be your skill
right that may be your strength or it
may be something like I'm really good at
putting on makeup or it could be that I
have a great sense of fashion it could
be any of those things and if you don't
know it yet you can also do an exercise
where you sit down with a colleague a
family member and a friend because you
need people from all areas of your life
and you ask them what do you think I do
that I excel in that I stand out in or
if you could trust me to do one thing in
your life for you what would that one
thing be
and when you ask that to people in a
reflective way really asking for that
presence you might be surprised by what
they say
and that's such a powerful question to
ask because someone may actually say
something like to you like Jay I think
your greatest strength is just knowing
what to say to me when I most need it
and you may think well that's not a
strength you can do anything with but it
is it is a strength that you can do a
lot with if you are okay with accepting
that of course I want someone to say to
me oh Jay you're you're an athlete like
Cristiano Ronaldo and you could play
football and get the Ballon d'Or and win
all these trucks but that's not my
reality
and so I feel that that's the place that
I would start with strengths
and there is a great study done on the
healthy wealthy and wisest people in the
world and they were asked if you could
invest in what you're good at
your average at or what you're bad at
where would you put your money and so if
you take a hundred percent how would you
divide that as a ratio
and if you ask this I want everyone
who's listening and watching at home
right now to do this exercise and you
may write down 33 33 33 you may write
down 40 40 20 you may write down 10 10
80 whatever you write down
the most healthy wealthy wisest
successful people on the planet will say
theirs is a hundred zero zero or 80 10
10. they go all in on their strengths
because they know that if they go all in
on their strengths they can become
exceptional at it
now here's the caveat
when it comes to your hard skills focus
on your strengths but when it comes to
your soft skills focus on your
weaknesses now you got to tell me which
is which yeah so hard skills are things
like excel math uh product design using
a video camera uh script writing
speaking these are all hard skills in
the sense that they're very clearly
defined very tangible uh you can really
measure them it's almost like a skill
that's measurable your soft skills are
like emotional intelligence listening
compassion empathy these are all soft
skills or considered soft skills and
those are where you focus on your
weaknesses because they can actually end
up tripping you up while you're trying
to become the best at doing the hard
skill so you may be the best
videographer in the world but if you
don't know how to listen to your
community and your team then no one's
going to want to work with you and so to
me that's the missing link that we're
we're actually the other way around we
put all our emphasis on getting better
at our weaknesses in our hard skills and
we think that because we're empathetic
and good people that that will be enough
and it doesn't work that way I just
really have had to build up rules around
my social media use you have so my rule
is never look at the phone first thing
in the morning oh my gosh I am really
trying this is my biggest one like I
think if we did this we would conquer
Our Lives I have now not looked at
Instagram first thing in the morning I
just look at like the text the email
okay we're good I that's good yep that's
huge it for me that's huge at one point
I actually used to put my phone and my
laptop locked in my car downstairs well
because that was the only way I could
truly convince myself not to look at my
phone and I think we have to go to that
extent sometimes or that extremity to
really push ourselves out of it so I
don't look at my phone until I go down
to the gym which is two hours after I
meditate and wake up and everything so I
try and avoid looking at my phone for
those first two hours and I find what
that does is it gives your mind time to
warm up you don't start your mind on
someone else's reactive schedule right
when you wake up and you look at that
email and you look at that notification
you're now thinking about everything
everyone wants you to do know what you
want to do right you're not thinking
about who you want to be or what you
want to achieve you're thinking about oh
Mary wants me to get that right you know
Julie wants me to do that right like
whatever it is like you start thinking
about everyone else's schedule and then
the third thing that happens is and I've
said this before but I think it's really
powerful when when you think about it I
think about this in the morning it
really stops me none of us and I mean
literally none of us would let a hundred
people walk into our bedroom first thing
in the morning that's true ever be
folding your hair before you do maybe
your makeup getting clothes on having a
shower you would never do that but we
let a hundred notifications enter our
mind
that's literally it's right trying to
shake our Consciousness awake right it's
like really trying to wake your mind up
you're expecting your mind going from
zero to 60 miles per hour in five
seconds when you open up Instagram or
Whatsapp or emails and it's so much
pressure on our minds that's really all
it is it's pressure and stress for your
mind to have to wake up and warm up way
quicker than our bodies do so that's
been a huge one for me that rule who's
the CEO of a very large car manufacturer
and he was known to be extremely
successful very productive very
effective
but the one thing he was failing at is
that his employees really didn't like
working for him because he worked late
how many of you feel that way
oh perfect that's good so no one here
finishes late or everyone's managers are
in the room uh whichever whichever way
you want to take it it's up to you right
it's up to you I don't know so that was
one of his challenges that his his
employees hated work for him because
they all left late because of him he
used to work till 10 pm every evening so
they would leave just after him true
story right they used to leave just
after him
so one of his assistants she came and
said this to him she said you know
morale's a bit down
everyone's struggling at work you know
we're losing a few people a few people
are quitting their work you know people
they're not well they don't feel like
their health is being taken care of
they're not spending enough time with
their families you really need to
consider this
he said okay leave it with me we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out
from the next week on a Monday
this gentleman who left at 10 pm every
night got up out of his desk at 6 pm he
packed his bag switched off his computer
left the office jumped into his car and
all the employees at this time are like
peeking out the window you know just
like making sure I figuring out where is
this guy going he pulls into the
beautiful car pulls out and drives away
from the building
it was the first time it had ever
happened at 6 pm
they all decided to wait till 7 PM
before they left they waited and they
left
on Tuesday the same thing happened they
looked out the window again he left at 6
PM again just on their way till 6 45 and
they left they did the same thing and
this happened for three months where he
left at 6 PM every day
three months later his assistant who'd
made him aware of this challenge he came
back to him and she said to him I'm
really confused about something she said
you've been leaving four hours earlier
every single day but you're not behind
on your calls you're not behind on your
emails and you're still performing at
the same level if not better than when
you were leaving on time and she said
how are you managing to do this are you
working at home well how are you
managing this he said let me tell you
something interesting he said every day
I get into my car at 6 PM I drive out he
said I take a drive for an hour he said
I take that drive I listen to music I
re-energize sort of sometimes go for a
bit of a walk at the park as well he
said I come back fresher at 7 pm and I
work for three more hours
and he said if it helps them knowing
that I've left at 6 PM so that they can
have a better life and have the values
that they want and value what they want
to give their time to that doesn't mean
I've got to give up what I value my time
to he said I love my work I love being
here till 10 pm I'm extremely ambitious
I love being here but they should also
love being where they are and that to me
is a incredible example of how someone
actually lives forgoing the perception
of others even though he changed his own
life to help other people they'll never
perceive him that way they just think
he's changed his mind and he goes home
early they don't realize the struggle
that he's putting in and that's what
I've realized whether you're putting in
struggle or sacrifice never look for the
validation or approval of others
to validate that sacrifice all that
struggle because they don't need to
understand anyway it's always been your
inner Journey it's always been part of
your inner growth and I remember when I
made a decision to become a monk after
business school all my friends are like
what the hell are you doing right we
just finished and everyone's going off
to work at Goldman Sachs and different
banks and consulting firms Etc I think a
few people came to Google as well and
they all said to me they said they said
what do you mean you're becoming a monk
like what does that mean like who
graduates and thinks about that and I
remember having to detach and when I
reflect and I'd love for you to do this
reflect on some of the best decisions
you've made on your life
ask yourself what decision did you make
what did people say about it and what
was going on in your mind I've learned
through doing that exercise it's a much
longer exercise it can take days and we
do it in our coaching exercises I've
learned that the best decisions in my
life have been the biggest risks
everyone's disagreed with me but I've
been hell-bent on making it happen and
so now when I see an opportunity like
that I do it because I realize that
that's the pattern of the philosophy of
my life when I make decisions that are
big risks no one agrees with me
and it doesn't fit with what Society is
saying those work out to be my best
decisions in life and I'm not saying
that that's your pattern I'm saying that
you have a pattern and a rhythm as well
and it's part of your journey to find it
after I've completed my work day when I
finished all of my tasks the last thing
I do is check my schedule for the next
day now I'm one of those people that
follows their schedule to a T I believe
it makes life simple when I get my
schedule out and look at the next day I
can think about how I'm going to feel
have I got too much or too little on
that do I want to add or edit something
it gives me perspective and allows me to
get a glance on the next day so I can
rearrange or reorganize based on the
energy I feel today sometimes we feel so
tired and exhausted but without making
that change in edit we take that
exhaustion in the next day the other
reason why I like looking ahead is that
it gives me an opportunity to mentally
prepare I may have a podcast the next
day and there's a guest that I'm really
excited about and I may have to calm my
nerves or sometimes it's an event or a
meeting that I'm looking forward to and
I just want to go over the bullet points
before I go to bed it gives me an
opportunity to rehearse the day in
advance and often I'll even sit and do a
short visualization just to imagine how
tomorrow will look Terry Pratchett a
famous author whether you've read stuff
or not a famous author he said that
people feel that stories are defined by
people but actually it's the other way
around people are defined by stories
when you're listening to me today I've
shared so many stories with you because
we Define ourselves by the stories we
tell ourselves on a daily basis the
story you wake up to will be the story
that will be the story of your day right
if you wake up and you tell yourself a
positive story you'll have a positive
day you wake up tell yourself a negative
story you'll have a negative day
positive and negative thoughts are like
seeds that either grow weeds or plants
right they grow inside of us throughout
the day anytime you plant something it's
like planting a seed and the more you
water it the more you think about it it
grows and of course if it's negative
it's like a weed and it starts to grow
and grow and grow and of course won't
bear fruits so really think about that
tell yourself the right stories connect
with the right stories because
ultimately the universe is made up of
stories not atoms and numbers right we
all love stories we breed stories your
life is a living story that you're
writing every day and I genuinely mean
that I spent years of my life working
really hard from Monday to Friday only
to have to wake up on a Saturday to do
all my cleaning not only did that take
up the whole day it made less time for
social interaction for connecting with
friends and family and even time to work
on my passions and what ended up
happening is that by the time it was
Monday again the house felt unclean and
I felt like I'd made no progress
initially we all believe that doing it
in one day seems like the best method
it's out of sight out of mind you don't
have to think about it for the whole
week and in one day you get it sorted
the challenge with that is that in your
mind it also feels like a bigger
mountain to climb scheduling it out
during the week makes all the difference
tackling small tasks per putting things
back immediately after using them
watching a play immediately after eating
something makes it so much simpler one
of the best ways to do this is to create
days dedicated to specific things this
makes it feel like a challenge or an
experiment so for example a wipe down
Wednesday knowing that all you have to
do is wipe down your surfaces may take
no more than five to ten minutes I also
really love floor Fridays now the floor
can sometimes take a bit longer but
still scheduling out around 30 minutes
to do that could make all the difference
and if you live with more than one
person you can divide these days and
these areas between you so that you can
make it simple and easier to handle and
Tackle there's quite a few benefits to
this when we do the same thing at the
same time on the same day every single
week it becomes so much easier for the
mind to tackle that task when we divide
and dissect our tasks up in this way we
avoid burnout we avoid feeling like we
have this big huge mountain to climb and
solve and we start tackling elements
every single day when you're feeling
anxious what's happening is that your
mind is either rushing to the past or
it's predicting and projecting the
future so you're either anxious about
something that you experienced before or
you're feeling really nervous and
anxious about something that might or
could happen in the future the best way
to come back into the present moment is
the 54321 method you want to start off
by looking around wherever you are and
noticing the five things you can see it
could be the windows the walls the
ceilings you then want to focus on the
four things you can touch it could be
something you're wearing and you really
want to feel the texture it could be
what you're sitting on just noticing it
and really grounding yourself and
holding on to that then it's about three
things you can hear it can be nothing it
could be white noise then the two things
you can smell in Hell could be a scent
you're wearing it could be a flower and
then finally the one thing you can taste
when you practice this it brings you
back into the present moment and helps
you not focus on the anxiety of the
nervousness but on taking action from
exactly where you are a lot of the time
we're trying to control anxiety up here
and what I find is hard about that is
that if you feel like you've got brain
fog or you're feeling cloudy it becomes
really difficult to find Clarity I find
using external things can be huge for me
I love diffusers and candles because a
diffuser is infusing the whole
environment with a beautiful scent and
it truly changes your mind if you walk
into a space just think of a spa as soon
as you walk in you feel different
because of the scent it could just be a
normal room with the scent of lavender
Sandalwood any of these essential oils
can truly calm your body right down some
people feel that silence creates anxiety
and some people feel that sound creates
anxiety sometimes times I like complete
silence it helps me relax and really
hear my thoughts and the thoughts that I
want to focus on and sometimes I need to
turn on some meditation music some
ambient music just to have that impact
on me please use music in your
environment in different rooms in your
home to help you achieve different
emotions and feelings that you want to
feel at that time what is the power of
service and how can we without going to
an ashram how can we take our strengths
and really give them purpose and meaning
yeah so one of the biggest things with
service in the ashram is service is a
part of your daily routine so there is
no choice about whether you serve or not
so that's a really great way to live
because you're almost exposed to lots of
different types of service so some of
that would be cooking for the homeless
or underprivileged children who don't
have access to warm meals some of it
would be building sustainable Villages
inside which people can live and
Villages can find a home and an economy
so you're always connected to doing
something for others but if I was going
to ask a monk why are we doing this what
would they say they would say because I
believe that you have to see how you can
be useful to others so the Dalai Lama
probably puts the best that
really we're born to help others and if
we can't help them at least don't hurt
them
and to me that really sums it up that
we're born to help others we're born
with different gifts with different
Geniuses with different talents to
improve the lives of others and the
question I always get from someone in
the audience who wants to ask me an
awkward question will be and there's
always one right and so the person will
say well Jay how does someone who has
nothing in India or Africa do this like
someone in in like a really slum
situation or a village situation and
they're always they'll always pick on
Indian Africa I'm not saying those and
I'll be like no but this isn't for them
I'm speaking to an audience that has
an education that has resources that has
Network like I'm speaking to people who
can make a difference so anyone who is
in that area of society has a
responsibility so anything that you're
given in life you're seen As a caretaker
of
and the way you take the best care of it
is that you use it in the service of
others and that purifies you from
becoming attached to it and it feeling
like it actually eats you alive and
feeds your ego
as opposed to you now being purified and
cleansed of wealth success Fame status
or time or whatever you have an energy
and you're Now using it for the highest
cause so that's what they would say they
would say it's the highest cause of
using what I've been given in the
service of others whatever you've been
given the Zen Story by the tea and I
love Zen stories and the books full of
them as as you know the Zen story is
where a student approaches a zen master
and a teacher
and is complaining about all the
challenges in their life and everything
they've got going on and feels like they
also have a sense of ego if they know
everything that's happening
and zen master sees a cup that's full
there and starts pouring tea into this
cup
and the cup just starts overflowing and
the students looking at it going like
what are you doing like how does this
make any sense
and and the Zen master says well you're
just like this cop right I can't put any
more in you can't take any more in
because you're already full like you
think you're full you think you're done
and and that's the point that you have
to always go back to that student
mindset you have to always go back to
that emptiness and I think one of the
reasons why we struggle with that is we
think that when we're full we're safe
our ego makes us believe that when
you're full when you think you know it
all that's when you're safe
craziest thing is that's when you're at
your weakest
and I think that's what we all miss that
when you think if you think of any
company that's ever thought that they
had figured it out that is when they
were at their most weakest point if
there's a fighter in a boxing match that
thinks that they have perfected this
game
that's one of the weakest when you're in
a relationship and you think oh my life
is perfect and everything's going great
that's when you are your weakest but we
find safety in certainty
when actually that's what makes us
complacent and lose the plot so that
story illustrates the need to always
reconnect not that we're empty that we
have nothing but that there is so much
more to gain there is so much more to
learn I've always had a rule since I
started that all my videos are 70
complete so that's my rule yes it's 70
that's all you're getting yeah there's
words that I say wrong there's fumbles
there may be a few mistakes here and
there the editing may be slow but it's
like my rule was 70 because that Journey
from 70 or 75 to 99
could take
decades yeah you can never it could I
would never release something and I'd
remember in 2016 after my first ever
video in one of my first videos that
went viral
I actually got so scared because it was
almost like oh I have to live up to that
now so I remember not creating yeah and
so I went from creating one video a week
to creating one video a month and guess
what I learned less
I was engaging less to connect with my
audience to understand what they needed
and what I was giving yeah and I was
trying less ideas which meant that I
wasn't learning you were learning I
wasn't growing at all I wasn't
progressing the world was being taken
from getting more Beauty from which came
from a place of not thinking like that
which came from a place of not trying to
be perfect exactly the original video
that did well came from a genuine place
of just wanting to serve and trying to
figure it out and then all of a sudden
we're not serving anymore so good and so
I was like okay this doesn't make any
sense and I was like actually and then
last year when we started making more
videos I can honestly handle my heart
say that when we started doing three
videos a week I started to learn so much
more yeah I was like oh I really like it
when I write like this and I really like
it when I create like this and the
audience really responds when I share it
this way and I was learning so much more
yeah and and I was feeling more
fulfilled by making more mistakes but
learning more so my mistakes increased
yeah but you're learning increases which
which was a much more fulfilling place
to be even though it was tough at times
but it was fulfilling the ego makes me
think you're untouchable and the ego
makes you think that you are you know
that nothing about you can can ever go
wrong or you're you're perfect or not
even that but the ego can bring you down
nothing can hurt you correct when the
moment you think you can't be brought
down you will be brought down the moment
you think that you can't let one of my
teachers would always pray that he never
and he's been among for 40 years he
would always pray that he would never
fall to his Temptations and we said to
him you haven't fallen to your
Temptation for 40 years why do you pray
for that he goes I haven't fallen
because I pray for it wow like he was
like because I pray for it because I
think it's gonna yeah he's aware and
there's a beautiful story of um Benjamin
Franklin where he talks about before he
died I believe he had 13 or 14 precepts
these were qualities that he wanted to
live behind gains though like Simplicity
Integrity virtues all these powerful
things and he was asked when he was on
his deathbed which was the one he didn't
accomplish and he said the last one that
was humility this is the beautiful thing
that happens when you say thank you to
someone who's kind to you it does three
things the first thing is you recognize
kindness so now you are triggering your
mind to start recognizing kindness and
you're now recognizing kindness in them
the second thing you do is you reinforce
kindness in them they realize they're
like oh when I'm kind people appreciate
it right so I'm going to be more kind so
you've now reinforced kindness within
them and the third thing is you help
them repeat it now that you've shown
them that their kindness is reciprocated
they're now going to be kind to more
people
so when you recognize kindness in
someone it reinforces that belief that
kindness is amazing and then they repeat
that kindness to other people so now
you've started this domino effect of
kindness just by thanking one person
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
like this video and want more J Shetty
check out another top 10 that I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
visualization the re-creation of images
sounds and environments before it has
happened is one of the most powerful
skills in the world